[Music]
Vegas is like constantly living under
stage lights Vegas is like the old-time
big movie set and Vegas is relationship
with drag is fantastic whether it's a
showgirl on the strip or a showgirl who
happens to be a boy in a nightclub we're
all entertaining people and this town
loves entertainment I'm Alex Serpa I'm
Daniel Honeycutt
we're the queens of Las Vegas and we
host what a drag
the longest-running drag show in Las
Vegas
[Music]
what a drag started in 1996 it's
everything in Vegas everything in
Hollywood everything on Broadway all
converted to drag our show is the three
C's costume character and comedy the
fact that we're a couple I think is the
reason why queens in Las Vegas has
managed to persist because we're a
unified front running the show when I
was a kid I would play in my mom's pumps
as I got older and I wanted to do drag
my mother bought me my very first dress
she saw that drag could be a creative
outlet for me that would help me develop
as a person I met Alex at 20 and I all
those years I had been studying drag and
Alex told me I see something in you you
know he came up with the idea of doing a
duet and he said we'll do it together
that way if you get scared I'm standing
next to you when I told him I can see
something in you what I was really
thinking I found somebody to do all
those duets that I've always wanted to
do when I start doing my makeup I have
to start with blocking out my eyebrows
not that I have much left yeah and from
there it's about creating contours a
contour is a permanent shadow and from
there you move on to eyes eyebrows are
really important fake an eyelash in a
fake eyelash they're always better the
second time he lived shaving oh yeah
the shape of a limpets bearish worn over
the lid patting the hip pads are shaped
like Africa and South America
respectively they're not just hip pads
are also but packed what I look for in a
wig is character and I'm partial to
blond
whatever number you're performing you
gotta have a gimmick the gimmicks gotta
last you all four minutes China Nicole
is a showgirl eyeing a gaudy she's
unstoppable Danielle Steel [ __ ] she's
the future drag and Alex and I being a
couple and both doing drag and hosting
the show we are family and then we're
also drag family so I've always had a
sisterhood around me when you come to
Vegas
whether you're local or you're a tourist
you get to be your true self
there's never boring moment what a drag
is like Las Vegas because we don't have
limits
just like Las Vegas
[Music]